nouvelle maintenant qui va vous faire
réagir si vous avez passé plusieurs
heures dans une urgence au cours des
dernières semaines la moyenne de la
grande majorité des visites aux urgences
ne serait pas d'une dizaine d'heures
mais plutôt d'un peu plus de quatre
heures
alors oui nous avons besoin
d'explications qui seront données par
josé petit bourg
si vous allez à l'urgence d'un hôpital
vous vous attendez à y passer 16 ou 17
heures en moyenne et parfois même plus
c'est ce qu'indique depuis des années le
palmarès des urgences publié par le
ministère de la santé des services
sociaux pour qu'il ne faut pas
s'inquiéter
sauf que cette donnée ne concerne que
les patients qu'on place sur une civière
parfois en attente d'hospitalisation
d'un test ou de transfert ça ne concerne
pas tous les autres on parle ici d'une
moyenne de 4 heures pour les patients
que l'on qualifie d' ambulatoire
ambulatoire quatre heures c'est nouveau
pourquoi n'en avoir jamais parlé avant
un vin on n'avait pas cette collection
de donner l'heure suffisamment précises
pour pouvoir l'affirmer c'est que depuis
trois ans les hôpitaux doit fournir des
données sur ces patients qui une fois
passé au triage sont vus très vite parce
que c'est justement urgent ou parce
qu'ils n'ont rien de grave qui nécessite
d'être placé sur une civière
les statistiques montrent qu'il sorte de
l'urgence après 4 heures en moyenne le
bilan que nous avons obtenus montrent
que c'est le cas de plus des deux tiers
68 % des 3 millions 400 mille patients
qui se rendent aux urgences chaque année
au québec
l'information paraît incroyable mais
dans les urgences
on le savait ça fait du bien d'avoir une
donnée là dessus et il espère que la
perception négative des attentes
interminables à l'urgence va changer les
gens ont besoin de savoir que ton va
l'urgence pas nécessairement parce qu'on
va attendre 24 heures
7 en moyenne c'est pas si mal que ça
dans les réseaux cela dit les moyennes
ne disent pas tout et même pour un cas
bénin et ambulatoires selon la région où
l'hôpital selon les ressources médicales
disponibles l'attend peut être pas mal
plus longue que quatre heures
comme par exemple en périphérie de
montréal mais elle peut aussi être plus
courte par exemple en gaspésie ou en
chaudière-appalaches est question josé à
montréal vous avez des données également
c'est à peu près comme la moyenne
québécoise
oui on va dire que montréal se qualifie
dans la moyenne québécoise évidemment il
ya des exceptions il ya les bons joueurs
et les moins bons le meilleur joueur de
rejoindre au real c'est saint justin où
on peut avoir une durée moyenne de
séjour à l'urgence qui n'est que de 3,2
eur donc c'est sous la moyenne
provinciale est le mauvais élève si on
peut dire c'est l'hôpital fleury qu'il
vit un mauvais bulletin puisque si on se
présente à l'urgence on risque de rester
là si on est en bulles à thouars
toujours non pas sur civière pour plus
de six heures donc ça ressemble un petit
peu à ce qui se passe dans la périphérie
de montréal et là-dessus faut se
rappeler que la grande majorité des gens
donc voie un médecin et sont soignés à
l'intérieur de quatre heures en moyenne
et que le médecin les médecins autant
que le ministre nous disent que si
jamais on pouvait avoir un meilleur
accès par exemple dans les gmf dans les
clsc ou dans les cliniques parce que ray
des heures d'ouverture le soir ou les
fins de semaine probablement qu'on
pourrait encore réduire ce temps
d'attentes à peut-être même deux heures
qui seraient une moyenne qu on viserait
en ce moment comme les autres provinces
canadiennes
et je vous rappelle en terminant que le
ministre barrette comme ses
prédécesseurs d'ailleurs s'y est
d'ailleurs engagée ben voilà c'est
intéressant josé ça va faire discuter
votre réagir votre reportage demande sa
scission en exclu on le répète les
malades qui sont sur civière à l'urgence
qui eux restent beaucoup plus longtemps
les gens dans une vingtaine d'heures
merci josé fort intéressant